Hello I’m Simon Whistler, you’re watching
the Today I Found Out YouTube channel and
in the video today we’re looking at why
beans give you gas.
It’s the job of your digestive system to
break down the foods you take in, allowing
the nutrients to “cross-over” into the
different body systems and organs for use
as fuel.
Each different part breaks these foods down
differently.
For example, the mouth chews it up into smaller
parts, and the stomach uses enzymes and acids
to further break it down.
The food then goes to the small intestine
where most of the nutrients that come from
our food (proteins, fats, and carbohydrates)
get absorbed into the bloodstream by a process
called diffusion.
What is left over is then passed to the large
intestine whose main job is the absorption
of water that remains in the indigestible
residue of food.
A smaller role of the large intestine is also
to break down polysaccharides (fiber) that
gets passed into it.
One type of fiber prevalent in beans is oligosaccharides.
Oligosaccharides are basically sugar molecules
that are made up of several different types
of monosaccharides (usually 2-10) to form
a polymer.
An enzyme that would break these molecules
down does not exist anywhere inside the human
body.
Therefore, when they pass into the large intestine,
they serve as food for the countless microbes
present.
While the microbes are processing these substances,
they release several different types of gases,
mainly hydrogen, nitrogen and carbon dioxide.
Don’t be concerned about these particular
gases, they are stench-free!
Your fetid flatulence affliction is from a
different source.
Specifically, about one-third of the microbes
end up producing methane as a result of breaking
down these sugars.
Once the methane builds up to the point that
it begins to produce pressure on your anal
sphincter…
That’s when the smelly magic happens…
Microbes breaking down these otherwise indigestible
substances is important for our health as
one of the by-products of this is the creation
of various vitamins that get absorbed into
the body, as well as for the production of
antibodies that help fight off certain types
of infections.
The downside is that the gaseous side effect
of these bacterial processes tends to clear
rooms everywhere.
You might have resigned yourself to the fact
you can never eat beans before going on a
first date, but fret not!
There are some methods to prevent your noxious
abdominal expulsions.
For instance, there is a type of mold called
Aspergillus niger that contains an enzyme
(Alpha-Galactosidase) that will break down
oligosaccharides, preventing your large intestinal
bacteria from creating gas.
You can buy it at stores everywhere under
the auspicious name “Beano.”
If you don’t want to be seen sprinkling
your beans with this product, you can always
try soaking your beans in water for several
hours before you make your food.
This softens the beans and allows them to
ferment.
The yeast produced can consume the offending
oligosaccharides and help leave your dinner
date vapor-free!